[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and lock up your nieces
this time is it because house of the
dragon episode 4 is now out and it has a
lot to impact from it the episode starts
off pretty slow with us following damon
as he does the x-rated version of a
whole new world from aladdin rhaenyra
ends up getting aladdin too and
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the big plot developments
ties to the books and also everything
you need to know about the show give a
big hand to the king by smashing that
thumbs up button and also make sure you
subscribe as we go through the series
week by week without the way a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into house of the dragon episode 4.
[Music]
okay so towards the end of the latest
entry we get an important moment that
sets up a lot of things for the future
though i normally do these breakdowns in
chronological order i actually wanted to
talk about the major development that
comes with a valyrian dagger first to
set the scene we join rhaenyra and her
father after the latter insists that she
didn't sleep with daemon in episode 1 he
of course told her about the dream that
had been passed from king to king and
this prophesized the rise of the white
walkers it also stay that a targaryen
had to be on the throne and here we get
more of the details on the dream and the
importance of the blade now we already
know from the main series that this is
used to kill the night king and i can
imagine that the show will end with a
major focus on it tying into game of
thrones in front of the oval area city
viserys brings up its previous owners
including anus
and egg on the concrete i don't think
it's anus but that's how it
looks written down now aegon was the
first targaryen king and he ended up
leaving all valeria conquering six of
the seven kingdoms beczerus son is of
course named after him and the title
sequence itself starts with an image of
all valyria which then fills with blood
leaving just his crown behind later on
daemon brings the character up and how
he had a second wife in an attempt to
justify why it's okay for him to marry
rhaenyra now as for the blade we hear
how aegon had the pyromancers inscribe
it we've met pyromancers in the game of
thrones series before namely the
character holain who created the
wildfire that was used in the battle of
blackwater the inscription discusses the
prince who was promised and how his song
will be one of ice and fire the song of
ice and fire ended up being the name of
the franchise for the books and sam
ended up writing this as well after jon
snow killed dany now the blade also
discusses the prince he was promised
which is a name that pops up constantly
throughout game of thrones the language
of it does differ slightly with the
person being called the prince that was
promised the one who was promised the
warrior of life and lastly the lord of
light now according to the prophecy this
lightbringer was going to be the savior
of their religion now an interesting
detail is that in high valyrian the word
for prince is actually gender neutral
because of this there was a lot of back
and forth at the time over whether the
prophecy was about jon or dany
melisandre believed initially that it
was stannis but after he was killed she
had a meltdown until jon snow came back
to life however another red priestess
and volantis believed that it was dany
and to make things more complicated
there are a lot of theories that
actually believe the prophecy is closer
to arya's life and the prophecy
basically says that someone of a royal
bloodline would be cast out and shunned
and they'd end up coming back and
killing the night king which hey if the
shoe fits now whether the killing blow
had to be delivered by them or they
could just be instrumental in the battle
remains to be seen and both john and
danny were big fighters in it too i've
always just seen it as being jon because
i'm a raging raging sexist i think arya
being it without us even knowing would
also be a good little way to interpret
the ending the episode itself opens on
rhaenyra's valerian necklace which was
of course gifted her by her uncle damon
this opening shot is very important as
the episode flashes out their
relationship a lot with uncle buck
turning into uncle
now he ends up asking viserys for her
hand in marriage and the idea that
renera can't find a suitable husband is
shown early on when we join her courting
men don't know if courting men is the
right term but it should be because
that's exactly what this is now it's
basically like a medieval take me out
with her dropping the buzzers on a bunch
of losers either cause they're too old
or cause they're too young we can tell
this is the home of one of the
baratheons as we can see there's sigil
on the wall and the guy beside ronero
wears this too here we meet lord
dundarin which i think might even be an
ancestor of beric barrick was born in a
small castle located on the dornish
marches which this lord brings up making
me think that the two are related
kristin cole also came from there too
and ray nero makes the pornish marches
with him later on i'm copyrighting that
for parody as they'll no doubt release a
house of the shaggins movie later down
the line now next we get boy blackwood
who carries a crow on his collar
denoting the house the family descended
from the first men and they have an
ancient feud with the brackens which we
see playing out here the bracken sigil
was a red horse on yellow which my man
from the side wears whilst he's heckling
reckon
which i was a bit annoyed at because i
paused the show and spent ages making
sure the sigil was right and that this
was a good detail but yeah hopefully
understand why the situation escalated
so quickly and little boy black leaves
him black white and red all over now
occur to rhaenyra returning home and in
a nice little bit of set design you can
see how the chambers on the ship also
resemble the royal chariot the cruise is
broken up by caraxes swooping in which
signifies the arrival of damon he's had
his haircut and do you know who gave it
to him the damon barber of fleet street
hey i said the damon barber of fleet
street having that
now if you've been following our
breakdowns then you'll know how he
talked about him getting given a kingdom
by lord corliss i'm not 100 on the order
of it in the book as collis basically
promised him rule of the stepstones
which is one of the reasons he was so
interested in joining the war he wanted
to gain something whereas hero kindly
comes across like he was rewarded it
after beating crabby there the book
simply talks about him winning a number
of victories that included defeating
crab feeder so for argument's sake we'll
say it was promised and then given after
the war was won as we've seen in the
show it wasn't the best of places and it
was pretty much just all rocks and
crappy lands where nothing grew so he
didn't really care about it that much
this is one of the many reasons why he
hands his crown and the area over to his
brother with the main one being to gain
his favor once more the book changes
things up a bit as it was during the
tournament that gave the green and
blacks their names in which damon
returned but they seemed to be holding
off on those two groups emerging for
later down the line and the books also
change up a lot of things with him and
my zarya in the source material after he
fled away with her he ended up getting
her pregnant and the pair planned to
marry however visceras put an end to
this and he ordered damon to send her
away and for him to return home during
her journey across scenario c she lost
the baby in a storm razier it never
existed now knowing what happens in the
book i actually love the way they play
her in the series and she's sort of
going to become this show's varys due to
her using spies and informants damon is
accepted by his brother and thanked for
taking our crab peter and his craw
people and they celebrate in the garden
viserys he's having the time of his life
and he drops his very funny line i
thought
perhaps prince damon would care for a
tour of the gallery
would you like to see
the tapes
hey the boys are back in town the gang's
back together and the book actually
discusses why viserys let damon get away
with murder literally and it says that
he held very fond memories of the pair
playing together as children alison and
rhaenyra end up discussing boys and both
kind of wish that they were in the other
shoes don't know why because alison's
getting banged off her dad but we know
those targaryens love keeping it in the
family now allison wishes that she
actually got a choice of men ras ranira
thinks it must be nice just living in a
castle and squeezing out airs kindness
sucks for both and the series will
likely follow them breaking free of the
confines of tradition in order to become
two of the most powerful people in the
realm ray and damon also talk and we
learn that it's been another year since
the events of last week
you've matured yourself these last four
years princess
last episode was three whereas this is
four and this is also confirmed by aegon
having his second birthday last time
whereas here in the play they say what a
little princeling of three
damon also refers to his wife as his
bronze [ __ ] which is one of the only
quotes in the book when discussing lady
ria back with the small council we see
that rey is now a member of it with a
new character working as the kubera you
also see that one of the lannisters is
on there too but it's difficult to tell
whether this is thailand or jason due to
them both being twins thailand did end
up serving as the master of coin however
it was much further down the timeline
though potentially they've shifted
things about now in the book thailand
all survived for ranira's hand in
marriage but whereas that rejection
didn't cause any tensions we see that
lord corliss is still annoyed about his
daughter he's now planning to add his
daughter with a sea lord son of bravos
and the alliance with the three cities
could end up causing a war thus they
have to seek out a marriage pact and
this of course ends up involving
rhaenyra who's tired of being railroaded
down a certain path after finding a map
to a secret passage hidden behind a
dragon doorway she ends up wearing an
emo disguise from the nordies and
sneaking out into the night loved how
she just had a beanie hat what looked
like a denim shirt and a white tee under
it and for a second although i was
watching a cutscene from infamous second
son now these secret passages lit at the
red keep and there's several articles
online detailing all of them paris knew
of a number of them after finding one by
accident and they were often given away
by candles flickering due to a draft
coming from beneath the doorway they
were built by margot the crew and it
could even be the path that says he took
when escaping the red keeper for her
death spoiler alert
now renews sneaks past the giant skull
of valerian which was the black dread
aka viserys's dragon she comes across
her uncle waiting for her and the pair
both hide their hair the targaryens of
course had the distinctive bleach blonde
look before it was cool and this made
them instantly recognizable ronira gets
a tier of the streets which align with
statues of dragons breathing fire and we
could see viserys in a bath covered in
wounds he's tended to by alison and
there's a sort of reversal here to the
scene with the queen from episode one we
see someone is back later which i can't
show because of what's going on in the
scene and clearly he's rotting away over
time with these becoming more and more
commonplace though i wasted everyone's
time banging on about grayscale for the
first two breakdowns i think that it is
just caused by the throne the cut on his
back was said to have been because of
this and he of course sliced his finger
which explains the removal of it and
also the other one it was said that only
the true kings and queens could sit on
it without cutting themselves and those
that received such wounds were cursed by
it probably just needs a tetanus shot or
something but the rust in the
bloodstream can mess you up the people
aren't too happy either and we cut to a
mock a play with its own throne this
details the conflict in the kingdom
about who will be the next ruler and it
doesn't go down too well with ronira and
damon now all the parts are played by
men referencing the olden days when
women weren't allowed in the theater
everything got bloody welcome didn't it
and they all had to get bloody woke and
start including women and furious these
plays have of course popped before in
game of thrones and they're used to
basically tell the overall events and
feeling of the people damon then takes
ranira to a brothel which is touched
upon somewhat in the book the paragraph
says at night he would smuggle her from
her rooms dressed as a page boy and take
her to brothels on the streets of silk
where the princess could observe men and
women in the act of love and learn the
womanly arts from the harlots of king's
landing now there are several varying
accounts of this and once more we hear
rumors from the gossip mushroom who
talks about what went on mushroom hasn't
shown up in the show yet but he's
mentioned loads in the book and i'm
actually surprised that they haven't had
them feature he said that damon taught
her tricks to use in order to seduce sir
cole but the buck has him rejecting her
whereas here he's all in a mushroom said
he began by giving her kissing lessons
from there the prince went on to show
his niece how best to touch a man to
bring him pleasure an exercise that
sometimes involved mushroom himself and
his alleged enormous member which if you
were telling a story about yourself
you'd add that in wouldn't you now
indicate with the scenes are shots of
viserys smashing allison like it's that
like button and she just kind of zones
out and thinks of happier times like
game of thrones season 6. in the series
there's no mention of kristin cole and
it's clear that the pair just want to
get it on but damon ends up walking away
renera is spotted by a young boy who
recognizes her because of her hair and
rumor starts to spread throughout the
entire kingdom i feel like the christian
stuff was changed to create more of a
love triangle between them all as the
knight of course also humiliated damon
at the tony in the book ranira got
rejected by him and she ran into the
night which is where she bumped into
harwin strong
you might remember that his father
lionel mentioned him last week to
viserys though he hasn't featured in the
show in the source material he was the
one who took her maidenhead which
maidenhead
is the 13th century way of saying her v
card at this point otto gets a visit and
we hear this apologies for later my lord
what is it a messenger brings word from
the white worm the white worm was the
nickname of mazaria along with misery
who damon ends up waking up to we don't
really know how the pair potted ways but
it becomes clear that she's building a
network in the city i have no idea what
her endgame is in spreading this to the
castle but if otto is the series middle
finger sorry littlefinger and she's
varys there could be a lot to it getting
otto to do this would have him removed
and as he's an enemy of daemon it would
allow him to ascend into certain
positions if damon owes her then she'd
have access to more power but the rumor
spreading causes a ton of issues you've
heard of plan b now hear of plan t has
rhaenyra is made to drink some that will
stop her getting pregnant now the scene
with ronira does have some subtext to it
and we already know that everyone has
been harping on at her that she has to
bear children however them giving her
this drink shows it has to be with the
right person and as rhaenyra says the
men can father as many bastards as they
want but when it comes to women they
have to have children in wedlock this
has to be with the right men the right
families and it's all done in order to
not cause issues it's very much a
comment on the double standards as well
as the prejudices that exist in the
realm it was thought that women would
stay with their children and these
bastards would end up living in the
kingdom rad's men would be happy to hump
and dump and never be seen again i just
the rumors of this make a lot of
characters mad at her and alison ends up
confronting her by the weirwood tree
it's a far cry from when she was sitting
on her lap in episode 1 and it further
shows the pair's ideologies fracturing
alison is slowly being disgusted by the
targaryens and she has to spend most of
her nights picking away at her
fingernails whilst viserys tries to put
another air in here now alison talks
about how the targaryens are and in fire
and blood they discuss how uncles would
often marry their nieces and aunties
their nephews the latter of these would
be touched upon with john and danny and
damon and ranira's relationship is sort
of a mirror of theirs damon shows up
with a hangover and to make matters
worse viserys almost ends up killing him
damon actually plays it up to make
becerras even angrier and he lies about
sleeping with rey in order to rile the
king up he wants a little chaos and for
viserys to feel out of control so that
he has more power over him now after the
dagger scene becerras tells rey that she
has to marry into the valerians and as
we saw last week he's also a dragon
rider rey agrees to it but she wants
otto out due to his conniving it's like
a firing scene from the apprentice and
viserys strips him of the hand of the
king badge without him giving too much
back in the buck he actually did this
because he kept hounding viserys to make
egg on the air whereas here it's played
out a lot more subtly otto actually
served three kings as the han in his
lifetime though he was removed from the
position at several points by the others
as well becerras brings up his father
and in the books he replaced sir ryam
who was mentioned earlier in the series
due to his death on a hunting trip his
father bailing complained of a stitch in
his side and he likely died of
appendicitis just five days later in the
tower of the hand we kind of get the
impression that otto is a snake or
lizard i think depending on whether you
watch spider-man or not and this talks
about his ascension he of course put
forward his daughter and got viserys to
check out his brother i was talking to
matt you know the lad edits the videos
and we were going over a lot of the
subtext of this conversation and how it
could be taken after watching it a
couple of times we did discuss how there
could even be the possibility that otto
ended up poisoning balin in order to
become the hand he could have then sent
in his daughter allison who is now doing
the same thing to viserys now none of
this is in the book and honestly i think
if viserys even suspected that he killed
his father that he'd probably have him
executed you know we just like over
analyzing stuff at the show though yeah
we thought we'd do that here anyway that
pretty much wraps up the episode after
some morning after tea and as for my
thoughts on it i know you guys love when
i review stuff episode by episode i
thought this was probably the weakest
one of the season so far even though it
had a great ending was texting matt as
we were watching it saying how it was
pretty mid but then when the last 15
minutes came in that all changed the
dagger scene was great and the boardroom
firing added a lot to it too i just
didn't really find the street stuff all
that interesting even if it did have a
big development with ronira and damon
probably sound like i'm completely
crapping on the episode outside of those
bits and i think in any other show this
would have been a great entry it's just
the standard of the other three was so
high that it's difficult to not feel
like there was a dip yet even if overall
it was still really good i love how the
town of the show has shifted and you can
really see the stress of being kane
getting to viserys everyone is
conspiring against him and whilst he's
trying to hold it together it's all
falling apart i think otto's removal
will likely cause a lot of issues with
alisond as she's of course been told
that her children won't be the heirs and
now her dad's out the job the parabol
carried out this entire thing in their
quest for power and they've spent years
with the king putting up with him in the
hopes of gaining it so this happening
won't go down well and i am excited to
see where they take things especially as
he's getting more ill every time we see
him now for the next part of the video i
want to talk about some of the spoilers
for what i think could happen next time
judging by the book these are pretty big
ones and i'd hate to ruin anyone's
enjoyment of the show so i'm giving you
this warning if you don't want to know
then thanks for sticking with me please
hit that like button on your way out and
i'll see you on the next one come on
that damon barber of fleet street pun
that was all right was now that deserved
a like now in the book ranira actually
ends up shacking it with lano and the
pair agree to wed however whilst all
this is going on to make stuff more
complicated damon actually ends up
agreeing to marry lena remember her yeah
yikes well it's been four years since
then so maybe next time it'll be six or
something but it is still a bit nancy
either way this helps to stop the
fallout that would be caused by her
agreeing to marry the other guy damon
actually ends up killing him so that the
wedding can't take place and i'm
expecting next week to center around
this moment now how he does this is
because lady ria ends up dying after she
falls from a horse i always kind of view
this as being like the opening of austin
powers 2 with him basically celebrating
that he's single again now in normal
circumstances this would mean that damon
was accepted as the leader of the house
of rice but here he was rejected from
this claim which is why he set his eyes
on lena this wedding is without the
consent of viserys so it causes even
more issues with his brother in the book
damon actually left the kingdom due to
the pair constantly arguing of course
the rumors that he was shacking up with
his daughter can see that all happening
within the next episode but who knows
where they could go most of my
predictions based off the book have been
wrong and it's clear that they're not
completely sticking to it so they might
end up skipping over certain things or
altering them in order to fit a certain
path either way i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show so let me know
below we are in competition right now
and giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on the
screen right now save that to you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want some else to watch then make
sure you check out our brighton of the
rings of power which will be linked on
screen right now it's another fantasy
epic another fun breakdown to be had
over there with some great puns so yeah
definitely go head over there right
after this if not love you for sitting
through this part of the video you take
care of yourself peace